jean christophe gallienne expert en
relations internationales et en
géopolitique bonjour merci d'être avec
nous alors pourquoi ces entreprises sont
elles soupçonnaient de ne pas respecter
les règles de concurrence et de nuire
aux consommateurs
il ya un affrontement qui est à l'oeuvre
entre ces nouvelles puissances des cités
et les unes et les autres et les états
et leurs premiers des états c'est celui
où elles sont nées c'est celui ces états
unis d'amérique qui aujourd'hui font
face effectivement à une une démarche
finalement qui est celle de dire
attention à ce que finalement notre
existence elle même est pas menacée dont
il ya un rapport de force qui est à
l'oeuvre à un rapport de force qui a
commencé avec l'histoire des monopoles
que comme par le passé aux états unis en
voudrait démanteler ou en tout cas des
coupes et il ya eu des ripostes par
exemple la lancement par facebook du
potentiel monnaie ce qui est exact en
une forme de souveraineté
hélas ce qui est visé c'est une quelque
chose qui pourrait être d'une nature
différente c'est à dire que les
entreprises auraient racheté si vous
voulez des plus petites entreprises
voire des très petites entreprises n'ont
pas dans l'idée simplement de grossir et
de grandir avec des services nouveaux
mais aussi de contraintes finalement les
évolutions d'innovation c'est à dire en
gros ce qui est accusatoire dans ce cas
là c'est à dire en fait finalement vous
avez tellement l'argent que vous pouvez
pratiquement neutraliser les nouvelles
innovations les évolutions dans vos
secteurs d'activité en rachetant des
entreprises qui pourraient être
concurrentes en tout cas de certains de
vos services et vous l'avez fait pendant
dix ans on qu'on regarde véritablement
et maintenant on veut y mettre un petit
peu un regard beaucoup empruntent bien
peu les rapports entre les pouvoirs
publics américains et sega femme qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur cette
agence indépendante américaine en
l'occurrence et agences elle vient comme
pour tout les secteurs
alors là en l'occurrence et ceux du
digital une partie
en tout cas une activité qu'on connaît
bien qu'on maîtrise bien à partir de ces
grosses forces l'idée c'est qu'elle
vient en permanence recherche et l'idée
qu'il y à une distorsion ou pas de
concurrence un petit peu ce qui s'est
fait notamment au niveau européen avec
les mêmes réflexes ou en tout cas un
raisonnement qui a eu depuis madame vers
styger au niveau de la commission
européenne donc c'est l'idée de quelque
chose qui viendrait encore une fois dans
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
large que celle cette seule affaire
encore une fois mais qui est très
importante parce que dira qu on assèche
la capacité d'innovation en rachetant
finalement et on tue ses concurrents
avant l'homme qui naissent où ils soient
va et revenant sur le marché c'est quand
même quelque chose qui touche aussi à la
concurrence est ce qui est l'objet même
de cette de cette agence dont vous
parlez est donc le but in ciné de
l'agencé indépendante américaine dans
cette enquête
c'est véritablement de d'éviter que les
nouveau nés soit absorbé c'est que cette
pratique finalement qui est méconnu qui
est lu depuis des années en tout cas
ceux qui accusent les ide entreprises
encore une fois d'organiser leur
monopole et de cultiver avec les
montagnes d'argent qu'elle génère chaque
fois la défense qui est une attaque
qu'elle pratique c'est celle de
finalement assez hachée alors ça existe
aux etats unis ben ça existe dans
d'autres parties du monde où il ya un
petit peu aussi parfois des positions
dominantes pour certaines activités
c'est pas propre digital ça existait en
énergie ainsi de suite la différence
c'est que la gare certain nombre de
faisceaux data qui font face ne se
trompent évidemment les a déjà le
proféré des menaces sur le fait qu'on
veut démanteler ces monopoles amazon
apple pour une partie google pour demain
selon leurs capacités parce que leur
taille et leur puissance aujourd'hui
économique et elle leur cuisson sur
leurs secteurs d'activité tels que c'est
un enjeu qui touche à la politique c'est
un enjeu qui touche quand on prend la
monnaie à la réalité de ce qu'est un
état avec facebook donc on est sur ce
conflit aujourd'hui de multiples entrées
et notamment sur celui qui fait que
voilà vous occuper un espace que vous a
séché vous tuez celles et ceux qui
peuvent venir
cela intervient dans un contexte
particulier puisque ce que c'est lié
finalement le
la proche de la présidentielle aux états
unis alors dans les déclarations de
donald trump certainement dans le
travail de l'habitat gens je ne crois
pas parce que les choses sont plus
complexes parce que ça c'est ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis mais lorsqu'on
touche audit l'entreprise depuis
l'extérieur notamment de l'union
européenne à ce moment là il ya un
réflexe effectivement sinon d'union
nationale en tout cas on a l'impression
que monsieur trois papes exactement le
même discours
encore une fois ça n'existe pas
seulement dans le secteur digital ça
n'existe pas simplement aux etats unis
c'est une pratique qu'il faut considérer
comme étant plutôt global quand vous
êtes sur un secteur d'activité que vous
avez beaucoup d'argent vous avez
tendance à vouloir éviter d'avoir des
concurrents qui danse dans vos pâtes et
c'est le cas là s'il s'avère que sega
femmes justement porte atteinte à la
concurrence
qu'est-ce qu'elle risque elle risque
finalement ce qui s'est passé déjà par
le passé c'est à dire finalement d'être
découpés démanteler j'y crois peu parce
qu'encore une fois elles sont dans une
capacité est de 6,2 dans ce rapport de
force de mobiliser aussi à travers
justement leurs moyens voir leur client
finalement que nous sommes tous en
partie en facebook c'est plus de deux
milliards et demi à travers la planète
deux personnes de ce rapport de force
qui surtout elles sont rentrés
aujourd'hui dans un jeu géopolitique qui
font que il ya des concurrents chinois
qui sont aussi des concurrents pour les
américains en tant que tel donc ça n'est
pas qu'un enjeu domestique au sens
national américain c'est aussi un enjeu
international et là la position la plus
difficile à tenir quand on veut découper
ces entreprises on s'affaiblit soi même
je ne crois pas que ça puisse aller
jusqu'au bout merci beaucoup
jean-christophe gallienne je rappelle
que vous êtes expert en relations
internationales et en géopolitique merci
à vous